can you tell the story
of um you escaping north korea
to china yeah i think
it's it's a thing it's amazing um
even though i was like 13 my like
life outside north korea it's almost
like you went by like one second
and my life till that point was like
eternity
i remember being in china i arrived
there at the end of march
at 13 and by october it was six months
passed
and i literally felt like i lived
eternity
and one day living in china
felt like living one year one day was a
war like
surviving through one day was so hard
every night i was like i cannot believe
i got done one day today
that was a thing i was grateful for
before i went to bed
okay i survived i didn't get captured
and i made you another day on earth so
the experience
of the minutes is is what fear
fear of being captured fear
loss everything itself
because i mean i sold my own mom in
china
to survive to so
it was more than that and it's not
feeling i think that's the thing
in china i learned not to fear
and after my skate was challenging i
didn't feel anything
and it was hard not feeling anything is
a torture it's a bigger torture you can
never feel like
even you fear sadness that's better than
not feeling anything
and i fear something
just overwhelming on the uncertainty of
your future did you have a sense what
your future
held at the time like what do you even
even feature i don't even know that word
why
like a lot of times i was looking at
myself like i left my body and like just
looking at me
and just not feeling it it's not like
i'm scared for her
i'm like sad for her just looking at me
like
oh that's interesting wow not feeling
anything
and me like being raped going through
every motion of life to survive right
like
but like like somehow i don't know
you say so or something like looking at
it just like
you feel nothing you don't feel anything
for that person
so even with your mom like what was
was there some
i don't know some warmth that you were
able to extract
from the connection with your mom yeah
of course i think that
made me survive i had a very strong
connection
with my family and i think that's what
kept me going
to do all of that i think as you said i
escaped at 13
my sister at the age of 16 escaped with
her friend first
and i was going to escape with her but
one day i got like really bad
stomachache
and my parents took me to hospital and
in north korean hospital they don't have
like x-ray machines like they don't even
have electricity
they like literally using one needle to
inject everybody
yeah and people don't die from cancer
north korea you die from infection and
fever and
hunger right it's most likely you're
gonna die more by being treated by
doctor than
not being treated i think i was lucky
even though they thought i had appendix
they they operate on me without any
painkiller
and i didn't get infection i survived
so that's how i got delayed to escape
with my sister
and she left me a note in my bedside
saying like follow this lady
and this is like another trick about
human trafficking right
she sold me to china as a sexual slave
and she executed fully later and she had
she was executed for that later she had
five daughters
and she sold all her children to china
and we can now sitting here judging on
like how heartless you are
selling your own children to china and
as a sexual slave they were like her
children were
7 10 years old but that was the only way
for her to save her children
and if she didn't start me that day i
would be dead right now
so i'm grateful that she started me and
i think that's the thing is life is so
crazy
you cannot judge he's just so complex
and yeah that's how she changed my life
by selling me
she sold my mom and myself in 2007 to
china
so you're grateful for that you're
grateful for that suffering
of course i am grateful because the
alternative is worse
i would not be here with you you never
knew i existed
you